When it comes down to the expertise of running transport operations,...
...I think then it comes down to you need the right people, coupled with the right IT systems...
...to run that and find the optimum solution and understand the logic behind it.
So I mean when we started, we looked for people with mathematical ability in the transport office,...
...actually making decisions as to what's the right thing to do.
So they were able to have an understanding, they have some ability to think logically.
You tend to find the guys actually really enjoy it.
There's a sense of achievement at the end of the day, when you've come in in the morning,...
...the A14 is closed, you've got all these suppliers that are chasing where the vehicles are.
And you're having to change your plan around live time, on the day, because things have gone wrong.
Once you have actually made all those changes...
...and at the end of the day the plan has then still been finished,...
...you have got all the deliveries made, everything is done and dusted,...
...you get a sense of achievement when you go home in the evening that it was a good day.
You wouldn't want it every day but, yeah, it is very challenging.
Well, once you are on the road you are your own boss,...
...and then you make all decisions of how you're going to get from A to B.
And that's what I like about it.
And you just seem to be so free in what you want to do.
You haven't got the pressure once you get going,...
...only when you get caught with traffic, that's the only thing.